temps de faire le tour du cru elles sont
là pour envahir les jardins cet habitant
de la banlieue de tours n'avait plus
d'autre choix
il a équipé ses arbres de pièges à suny
lorsqu elles descendent vous il ya des
professions un peu partout et c'est
surtout près dé toucher ça peut pas bon
pour les animaux ça peut aller ça va
chez les voisins donc mes voisins
considère que c'est ce sont des choses
et donc se plaît depuis quelques années
des communes impose même aux
propriétaires infesté de se débarrasser
des colonies c'est le cas de ce
tourangeau qui a choisi de faire appel à
un professionnel et opté pour la méthode
de l'éco piège grâce à cette collerette
de plastique
les chenilles sont bloqués dans leur
course elles descendent dans le sac et
sont alors prisonnière la configuration
du jardin on pourrait passer dès qu'une
nacelle pour traiter les arbres et d'une
part et pour aller et chenilles et
coupez les cocons c'était c'était pas
possible donc c'était vraiment la seule
solution qu'on avait pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir remédier à son problème
sept spécialistes étudient la
prolifération de ces insectes
un phénomène accentué ces dernières
années par le réchauffement du climat
les jeunes y gagne le nord et deviennent
citadine l'expansion des villes il ya de
plus en plus habitations qui sont qui
sont construites à l'orée des forêts et
là où la processionnaire du pin et l'a
naturellement et donc du coup ils et
elles ont tendance à arriver dans les
villes des junies à surveiller ce
printemps car elle représente un risque
pour la santé qui va de la simple
réaction cutanée à des lésions plus
grave des yeux ou du système
respiratoire